hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to i last were parsing
thumbed also known as i let a sketchy
website pick a random steam game for me
to play i'm back at it again for another
wheel of punishment where my desires are
irrelevant and everything that i want to
do is ignored and i let my destiny lie
in the hands of people that programmed a
website that i don't understand there's
a wheel
and it's random so let's find a random
steam game for me to play
[Music]
night trek productions dungeoneer
dungeoneer nudity
[Music]
it is what it is and i have to play this
game don john ear that's what it is
on here
[Music]
i feel like this is just the intro to
the game and i want to go in blind so
i'm going to do this nobody look look at
my face look at my eyeball don't look at
what i'm doing
how big is this game five gigabytes it
did not look like a five gigabyte game
is that cotton candy
also what is off to the left
for dragon
skills i don't know what
what what why why am i able what
why done what
what
oh
there we go
that's better download's done
scribes
oh
it's literally the people that made it
every 30 seconds of action takes about
10 hours to render okay
long scene to render oh
okay
i don't even know what type of game this
is i didn't even read can i
play
can i can i can i play
can i
hello hello hello okay your mission oh
dire shade fortresses
was abandoned millennia ago after an
unknown dark force erupted from the
earth beneath it forming a dungeon
filled with unknown terrors visited by
the foolishly brave never to be heard
from again for the fortress has been
marked a no-go area by all who know it
but now the darkness alerts they are
spreading outwards from dire shade as
some dark force grows within its dungeon
with his kingdom threatened the kingdom
the king the king has chosen you his
bravest knight to venture to die a shade
fortress your orders
do orders your orders enter the shape
dungeon overcome its dangerous layout
traps and moon stairs find your way to
its core and destroy the darkness
growing there
all right oh
there's more story
as you approach starshade fortress make
sure you are prepared for your quest to
head seeing the world through your eyes
find your way into dire shade fortress
and find the entrance into the
mysterious dungeon which is erupted from
the ground beneath it explore your
surroundings find items and spells that
will help you on your way and be
prepared for anything your hand helps
you explore the area ahead and use
objects in your inventory directions
i'm bored begin quest
[Music]
i gotta admit the game is kind of wowing
me so far
it's not bad it's low resolution if you
think it's pixely it's because it is
for some reason it's playing at potato
resolution
a problem because that was the
limitations of his ability to render in
time
it's been a long journey but i'm nearly
at my destination
[Music]
better check my equipment before i
proceed
my equipment i have a shield
and i have a sword knife hands three now
the book restore
poses a spell
i wasted my mana
probably i wasted that spell entirely
i'm dumb looking hard i'm going
how did i hide this again tab
space oh god i skipped i didn't mean to
okay
darshad fortress i'm here now now to
find an entry into its dungeon maybe the
door
oh
animatic
animated
animaniacs
knock knock
i did not expect that to actually open
what is that black void why can't i see
beyond the doorway
good question
i'm going in
[Music]
what where's the door i just came
through i'm trapped great
i see a gargoyle
ah
these are pretty slow aren't they
i think you could have saved some time
by speeding up the movement creepy
creepy
but what is it why is it here it's a
gargoyle and it's here because it's a
gargoyle
the path of gresh in the path of defense
if you want both pass you must paint
blood
oh my god
that's a bold choice man bold choice
let's see if going back
oh yeah god if you had to render every
single in and out at this speed no
wonder it took a lot of time
no wonder
this is with the ball what's with the
ball
strange light i've never seen anything
like it before
all right cool story
oh my god
oh god what the hell
what the hell
did i just pay in blood
did that come down on my head
ow
or am i tiny
am i tiny now i feel like i'm tiny oh
[Music]
what
what choose a path and enter my dungeon
dark core
what are these scripted messages and who
or what is dark core
let me back away from this
i'm not picking that you're picking
enough wait wait no no no no no no i did
not pick that
i did not pick that okay
good god no wonder this took so long for
you to render
oh my god i get it one go uppy one go
downy me understand
i go down please do not take as long as
you did
oh my god oh my god
oh my god hey what's up guys i'm here
i'm taking my time
i want to be cautious i don't want any
port college gates slamming down on my
nog hey is there a brick about to fall
on my head
is this the entry into the dungeon
wouldn't be my first assumption
but let's go
level one oh that wasn't even the ah i
wasn't even playing the game initial
explorations progress saved
sounds good
oh my god
where am i it's dark here is that light
i see a head
i don't know
is it
is it light you see a head
it is
his light
his light i see a head
excellent
well
great i don't feel so good good god what
happened to my face am i okay
hello
uh i'm not sure that's how people die
but if it is that'd be pretty horrifying
which that is
[Music]
great
excellent
oh a scroll
oh yeah
oh no no no that's cool but no
no no i can already tell how long that
will take to get up those stairs i'm
just going to read the scroll i'm hoping
that's the answer i turn around i get
out of here this is only one correct
path make sure you take it
[Music]
what
oh no oh god oh no oh god
i don't even want to know what made that
giant skeleton and it's huge
i usually you go up the stairs you don't
go into the void next to the stairs
my friend my bro
my buddy my pal
there's only one correct path i hope i
take it
i really hope i oh my god
why is it so slow
[Music]
[Laughter]
there's only one correct path
i better pick the right one
[Music]
i'm guessing it was a riddle in that
you can only pick the right path
i'll take the left one please
ah there i go oh wait my skull appears
and then i'm dead my skull appears at 50
and then i'm dead i didn't know how
accurate this picture would be i
legitimately just picked that at random
for dungeoneer i didn't know that it
would be my face after i was
gone i uh can i leave a review please
a particularly life-changing experience
in that my
life was technically moving forward as
the beauty
of this game unfolded before my eyes
it almost felt as though i was nearly
along for the ride
on this majestic
continent spanning
adventure
will be unto thee who underestimates
just how much time
you will
put into this game
because of the
fun
of course
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa be unto thee i recommend this game
thank you very much that was wonderful
life-changing fantastic all right time
for another game that was
truly a life-changing experience but i
must move on on to the next great
adventure
honestly i can tell though that had like
a lot of
it had a lot of spirit you know it had
obviously that took a lot of effort
obviously
obviously that took a lot of effort and
i do not fault it for that
total ski jump
well the single player multiplayer pvp
shared split screen pvp remote play
together okay total ski jump total ski
jump
oh car
or what
what an interesting soundtrack nobody
look nobody look nobody better be
looking nobody better be looking if
you're looking i'll stab your eyes out
i'll burn them oh that's a reasonable
it's like 88 megabytes that's great
that's good oh my god shut up
oh god fps
play
oh
perfection games
okay well i'm not much for customization
but i might as well do the player editor
okay
wow okay
jonathan roberts i can't change that
hello
no random oh
oh
all right helmet color
red
oh my god i'm not doing this i'm gonna
random ten times and that's what it is
one two three four five six seven eight
nine ten
this is him skills
no landing skills all jump no land
save him love him go back
start game jonathan roberts
[Music]
player oh there's one oh
uh
all
all continue
select hills usa
i guess
all
hell
i'll try that later if this goes too
slow oh how do i play
i'm going now
i'm playing
i'm jumping
what
what what
what er
[Music]
okay
i'm flying
oh
now i'm getting the hang of it now i'm
getting it
i don't know if i'm getting it i don't
know if i'm getting the hang of it
i'm flying oh yeah you know i'm flying
i don't know what i'm doing i don't know
what the frick i'm doing i don't
i don't understand um put some epic
music behind this
uh make it seem lots of explosion having
guns shooting in the air trying to get
me down but you won't get me down
they got me rockets flying through the
air and attack apache helicopter goes by
three jets
chaos here in the sky jump oh he's going
for the gold but he may not make it
because he's about to die that was a
terrible jump i'm gonna go uh because
i'm about to make the god of uh
listen methju is gonna be
literally
unbelievable it's it's meff juice time
to shine and the only place for me is in
hell pick all off we're going to hell
what
[Music]
what all right we're getting out of hell
we're going to slovakia
what is this garbage jump we're going to
japan
that's not a jump what is that japan get
a better jump
go
what is this crap
germany i guess
okay it's the one with the it's the only
one with an actual ski jump okay great
all right get ready jonathan you're
about to get your ass so unbelievably
kicked
like kick to beyond all recognition
here we go here we go all this training
all this training all the training
training of the gods training of the
gods training of the gods training of
the gods
[Music]
on board can i leave a review i did play
it i played it for more than a minute i
definitely played it for more than a
minute come on guys come on i played for
way more than okay
[Music]
is it about riding the wind is it about
riding the wind like a bird
it's about riding the wind like a bird
this doesn't make any sense i don't know
i don't know
well that was fun thanks guys that was
great oh my god can i please
i've played it so much
i played it i played it now i played it
wait do you think that this is the game
does steam think that that is the game
steam thinks that the that this launcher
is the game
that's what steam thinks the game is
that's why it says i've only played for
a minute well let me just play with
these controls here oh wow look at the
numbers well i'm gonna let this soak for
a bit
i'll be back
with my beautiful review
ha ha
[Music]
i got a snack figured i'd eat
because i have time it's like a snack
board
a charcoater
well five minutes
is that enough to write a review
it is all right
the english
language
is woefully
insufficient
when tasked with the challenge of
attributing
the correct vernacular
towards
describing the magnificence
of the experience of playing this game
no
no greater mystery has ever captivated
my attention
quite like the
mechanics of this
game
true to its name
it is total
complete
and complete
the
very essence
of this
of the young of the jump distilled
into a single
moment of glorious
flight
you will
definitely jump
no you won't no you i can't make that
clean okay i recommend it
reviewed
great
good job another game in the bag thank
you sketchy website for not ruining my
life and stealing my information please
do not
please
roll again
i don't trust you
i don't trust you at all
delete knights
nice
[Music]
realm of altars realm of altar
for realm of altars realm
of altars what the hell is real free
oh no
[Music]
well it's free
so i'm sure it's not filled with uh
pay to win stuff in that oh [ __ ]
inapp purchase is great
i mean that was a fast download
and this is
i wonder if they're trying to tell me
something
why
guest
i am a guest oh markiplier you know it
baby
i need
oh
god so many batches look good think i
have my snacks
well
we want a will we now will zones little
bossy
i see your name is markiplier too
nice to meet me
[Music]
wake up i'm awake
who am i i didn't ask that i'm percy did
you forget that we met in the forest oh
that forest right no time to explain we
need to run
oh i thought your name was markiplier
you aren't going on anywhere you're
ready i need your help
[Music]
oh i play first
okay
i don't want this and i think it's
obvious why
the beginning of the value you'll get
five cards you can swap to
oh so it's like a decky big decky game
it's a deck building game
okay all right
there's a follower card you can summon
followers follow oh man there's so much
to learn um
you need me okay let's put a card in the
mana zone
what
i banish you to the mana zone with you
oh that was really how
he's dead now
okay
so i'm gonna follow her
[Music]
long press i i don't know what you mean
i did
[Music]
god this [ __ ] tutorial
we need yellow mana to trigger the
ability of smuggler mic smuggler
for the magic thunderbolt okay all right
let's do that okay
smuggler mike
[Music]
i don't know what's happening and i
don't care i'm just going to start
throwing things around here where there
or wherever it tells me to
oh yeah you know it this there yeah that
there this there bam this you hey boom
bam
oh yeah
oh
oh my mouse mike
smuggler mike
take this and this
[Music]
100 starting i'm sorry that's a lot of
what
get all
oh
right
okay
chop
but i don't think so i
what is that
skipper
three
god they're all the same they're all the
same they're all the same mobile games
these days they're just a [ __ ] book
recipe god
it's such a depressing nightmare
landscape of nothingness well
i think i'm good i think we've all had a
good time here that's great the
artwork's pretty though
my hands are a
broken ruin this game
held them so tight
my bones shattered
mere moments after opening
the game
but there was
yet a warmth
[Music]
a warm
bosomy
but
bosom
was awesome there was a warm
bosomy
warm bozomy warmth
that spread
that spread from devastating
that
phalanges
they're devastated
fairlangies at the core of this game is
a giant pile of
bounce
[Music]
that can only be prized free with the
truest tool of all
[Music]
nope i yearn
yearnily
for that warmth
to touch me once more
but maybe not so hard next time
sure
well that will do it for today thank you
sketchy website for picking these
wonderful steam games for me to play
what would i have done without you
random chance is the only way forward in
life my dna is practically scrambled
with the delight that i felt from these
games that i played today and i hope you
enjoyed them as well i won't even bother
linking them in the description because
they've been burned so deeply into your
psyche you can find them if you'd like
to go for it on steam today thank you so
much for watching if you want more of
this let me know down in the comments
below and thanks again and as always i
will see you in the next video bye-bye
[Music]
you